heights Evan Carmichael today I'm doing
another one of my fiber gigs where I
review somebody's website give my
feedback on it and showcase them on my
youtube channel so today's website is
server cs6 teen class client su I
checked it out the website is not in
English and I thought I'd give it a shot
so let's load it up and see what kind of
feedback we can still give even though I
do not understand what a lot of this the
wording is so this is the website Google
lets me know that this is in Russian and
I'll probably translate it but let's
check it out first the design is okay
there's a lot happening i'm not quite
sure where I should be clicking next you
might want to invest into having a
slightly better design that would
attract people and quickly guide them to
let them know what your next step should
be as I scroll down here there's a lot
of different pictures some of them seem
broken so no image here broken picture
broken picture down the right side
there's a whole bunch more broken
pictures so you might want to get that
looked at see if these are important
sections of your website or not and if
they are fix up those pictures so that
they can help help the people or visit
in your site so let's translate this and
Google does not do a perfect job of
translating but it's better than me
trying to guess what all this stuff is
about so next I'm looking at the title
tag of the page and it's all for CS 1.6
in general you want to try to optimize
your website maybe a little bit more
that's probably not much of a search
word a search term all for CS 1.6 so I'd
be a little more descriptive in your
title tag so that you're using your
search engine keywords a little bit more
here it says download the materials on
the site or for all users this internet
portal is designed specifically for
rounds of the most popular game of all
time' nations
counter-strike now again the English is
broken here because Google is doing the
translation so this is your call that
this is this is your call to action kind
of explains what it is that you do i
would put this higher it's not very
visible kind of gets lost in the shuffle
so if i landed on this website it
wouldn't quite know what you're all
about so i make this a little bit bigger
more visible easier to understand in
terms of your you know called actions
i'm not quite sure what to do next looks
like there's a group here that looks
like facebook but maybe it's like a
russian version of facebook there I
don't see any newsletter or way to
convert some of your visitors so you
want people who are coming to your
website to not just come once and leave
you want to try to hook them and so if
you can sign them up for your newsletter
offer them some kind of bonus or free
value add and then when they you know
they you have some kind of new update on
your website you can let everybody know
I'm bring them back to your website so
let's check out another page just look
at the about this site here and see what
we can find out so again I don't
obviously understand what this says but
it's very condensed that makes it really
hard to read it's good that you have
some content here but it's hard to read
the font size and everything bunched
together let's translate and see what
we're talking about here 36 tips while
playing CSS or counter strike so this is
great that you're offering some value
out for people these 36 tips but what I
would do is have a little bit more
information about the site you know what
are you offering here on the site why
should people take that next step what
is the next step that you want people to
take
so people are curious to know about your
website your business and why you got
started so you want to use that as an
opportunity though she sent just the
second link here on your menu that's an
opportunity to connect with people let's
check out one more page to see our
forums and see what we have here in the
forums so there's not a lot of activity
I don't even need to translate it to see
there's only a few posts in general and
they look like they're from 2011 so
stuff like this makes it look really
dated and really old and so if I saw
this as your forum I may not want to
check out the rest of your page because
it looks really outdated so I'd either
remove the form since nobody's really
using it or make this part of your
business and really encourage people to
drive you know to your form and get them
involved in it and maybe that's
something you put on your homepage make
it really visible the next step is to
you know join in on your forms but one
of the other either remove it or make it
more visible and really drive people to
that page one thing I see a lot of
opportunity here is to tell your story
and so I haven't seen that anywhere it's
not on the homepage it's not on the
about me page why did you start this
people are interested in learning about
who the person is behind every business
most people like to buy from people not
from companies so if you could talk a
little bit about maybe why you like
counter-strike so much and why you
started this website and what you hope
to accomplish Amadan what you want to
share that's a story that could really
bring people in and make them want to
take whatever that next step is with you
maybe make a video of yourself or if
you're not comfortable with that just
take a picture of you you know smiling
or playing counter-strike or whatever it
is just to add a little more personal
attachment then then just what you've
got right now so hopefully that helps
always a little harder when the websites
not in English but I hopeful there's
still some valuable feedback in there
that you can use to make this website
even better than it is those are
watching if you liked this video and you
found the information helpful please
give it a thumbs up below it makes one
to do more for you and if you have a
comment about this website or you have a
question by your own business or website
feel free to leave it in the comments
section below I always read those I love
seem to come in so thank you and I'll
see you on next episode
you